the people who are leaking this have
found footage of Tucker according to
Media Matters acting really really
creepy okay I'm not you know what I'm
not qualified on that score I will say
I thought his girlfriend was kind of
yummy
just kidding just kidding cases being
pulled off to bird
yeah the bird hey Media Matters for
America go yourself that's the
first thing I want to say tonight second
thing is totally kidding I don't even
know what his girlfriend looks like and
if I did I would not find her yummy
and if I did I would not find her yummy
that's a great bit that's a great bit
it's not there's nothing creeping
there's nothing lecherous he's joking
about this as if it's on camera